[Music]
our history Manawa Schaffer is at the
45th Tokyo Motor Show in Japan most of
the exhibitors here are Asian
manufacturers he says presenting their
new concepts and ideas but German
companies also come here to display
products because the Japanese market is
one of the biggest and most important in
the world
Volkswagen Porsche and Alpena are among
the German brands but Toyota is one of
the main attractions they have several
new concept cars to present the concept
I Series is Toyota's vision of future
mobility it uses an artificial
intelligence system to recognize the
emotions of the passengers and the
attention level of the driver so it can
react accordingly if the driver is
distracted in a dangerous situation the
car intervenes and switches into
automatic driving mode
the crown concept is a little closer to
actual production it continues a legacy
of toyota crown cars the comfort model
is the most popular taxi vehicle in
Tokyo the concept car uses Kinect
technology to share and receive traffic
information to help ease the flow on the
roads
Thoma show Burger Toyota thinks the car
makes a strong impression at five meters
30 long it comes as a 12-cylinder model
but that's only for the likes of the
Japanese Emperor there are smaller
engines which are still very impressive
it only comes in one equipment line and
it has all the luxury you could possibly
imagine 13 I'm sorry no the faster you
come a bit less luxurious but far more
efficient that Toyota fuel cell bus
which will be out on the streets of
Tokyo next year I know that one car
that's really made an impression on our
car tester is the Mazda Kai concept he
just hopes it goes into series
production like this the compact model
is a nod at what's to come in the new
generation of Mazda cars among other
features they have the new skyactiv X
technology installed under the hood
yo Herman tiga from master says this
concept car couldn't go into production
exactly as it is but the basic design
and proportions would be transferable to
a production vehicle in the compact
segment as what features like the offset
driver's compartment which is typical of
Mazdas Kodo design philosophy
even more futuristic the must of vision
Kupe the name is an homage to the
elegance of classic goofy models like
the Mazda R 360 the brand's first-ever
car and the rotary powered mazda luce
also known as the r130
over at Lexus it's the LS plus concept
car in the limelight it's on course for
series production starting 2020 the
highway teammate advanced driver
assistance offered several autonomous
driving functions another highlight is
the brand's flagship model the LS 500 H
which is already primed for series
production tire companies like Dunlop
Falcon and Bridgestone also featured at
the exhibition as well as components
manufactured Denso showcasing its latest
developments a few quirky creations also
made an appearance like this micro
kitchen car from Takayama it's a fitted
kitchen on wheels
perfect as a mobile snack van when
you're done with work and ready to drive
the car slides together along rails the
biggest advantage is its compact size
[Music]
detective Amanda thinks the technology
side of fuel cells electric cars and
hybrids is sometimes seen as a little
dull but car makers here of Sheldon
doesn't have to be he for one was
fascinated by the Tokyo Motor Show 2017